after hearing that frontline workers
were running out of ppe
seven-year-old haley orlinski decided to
sell
homemade bracelets with the hope of
raising 200
for her local children's hospital well
today she has raised more than 27
000.
i have chills everywhere from chicago
illinois
please welcome hayley and her mom lori
oh my gosh i'm so excited to meet you i
really do have chills
all up and down my body i mean lori i
have two daughters
you must be so proud my goodness i can't
even tell you how proud we of who we are
um initially i thought this would keep
her busy for two hours and then i
thought maybe it would keep her busy for
a few days and we are going on ten
months of uninterrupted time
for a mom that's great and as a mom
myself
hayley i just want to ask you how did
you get the
idea to start this project so originally
back in march
when we were under the stay-at-home
order my mom was watching the news and i
overheard that the doctors and nurses
were running out of masks and other tv
equipment so i really wanted to help
but i didn't know how so i ran up to my
room and made
these friendship bracelets and i told my
mom
i want to sell them and raise money for
one of the hospitals
okay so you've sold over 10 000
bracelets now
why was it important to you to be a
caretaker
to take care of others to give back
so i decided to give back to larry
because i was in the nicu there and that
and this is my way of giving back to
them
and haley was when she was three years
old she was bullied because she was the
shortest kid in class
and so she's very empathetic because
she's been there and she feels
all the feels i ended up writing a book
about
her journey it's called being small
isn't so bad after all and so
haley and i prior to covid we go to
schools and libraries and haley talks
about
spreading kindness and so this is the
ultimate act of kindness
i i'm just in awe of both of you
and i heard you have actually a special
announcement we get to do
with you tell us about it yes i have a
huge announcement
my bracelets are going to be in the
grammy swag bag
oh my goodness by the way speaking of
grammys
seven time grammy winner the
phenomenal carrie underwood
is loving what you're doing
what's your favorite song i love before
we teach
we actually had someone here that wanted
to say thank you as well
hi haley
i i wish so much that i
could be looking at face to face in
person
right now you're adorable uh but you're
a perfect example it doesn't matter how
old you are
where you are what whatever it is that
you're into you took your love of making
bracelets and
you used it to make the world a better
place so yay
you're freaking out right now she's
crying
i'm gonna cry
haley we just want to thank you for all
that you've done
to help your community and as women and
mothers to imagine
any child doing what you do is such
an example and we'd love to donate to
your charity as well
so i'm gonna contribute five thousand
dollars
[Applause]
and carrie yes uh me
and my family at body armor light are
going to contribute
5 000 as well so that's
my gosh that's going to help the
hospital
and it's going to help with vaccinations
and we are so thankful
wow wow
thank you for having us and drew haley
has something special to tell you that
she found out about the two of you
we're birthday twins february 22nd
okay again i just have like chills this
whole time
it's been like five minutes straight
without uh
fading uh haley do you mind if we like
call each other
and say hi in a couple weeks for this
birthday
oh my god i would love that great we all
need connections while we're separated
so that would definitely be something i
would look forward to
find your path and fit 52
these beautiful word worlds that carry
underwood has
brought us into and created i thank you
so much carrie
for your music and just
everything that you put out into the
world is so beautiful and
positive thank you carrie thank you
haley and lori
thank you so much you guys for being on
the show
thank you